foreign
[Music]
and the rest of you play double time
[Music]
Spidey Splinter the Wishing Star is in
here somewhere Kitty may I please see
the map now seriously you won't let me
hold it for even one minute nope not
even for one second come on Kitty you've
got to trust me
wait wait what's what's going on with
his eyes oh they're getting bigger oh
Kitty
Kitty trust him look at those eyes
really you call that cute
oh look at her those eyes are even
bigger than yours do whatever she wants
puss wait a second so
[Music]
no
with the pause come on what the heck
it's all so cute
oh
can we look at the map now uh listen
doctor thanks for everything you know
but I am feeling great strong like a
bull you know now do you know a good
place to get some please this is serious
what is it for some boots
how do I say this
who died
relax I have [ __ ] boots I laugh at
death
you see and anyway I am a cat I have
nine lives and how many times have you
died already
uh I don't know I never counted I am not
really a math guy you know you are down
to your last life my prescription no
more Adventures for you you need to
retire me retire Are You The Village
comedian as well you're talking cat I'm
a talking cat let's talk
up I'd rather eat oh not a problem we
can even talk at the same time no hablo
English
I don't speak Spanish either you're
funny
okay good talk oh hang on
pickles is that your name I'm no expert
but you don't look like a pickles well
you don't look like a cat
okay okay full disclosure I'm not a cat
I'm a dog
meow oh pickles has a new girlfriend
the wolf found me
[Music]
hello Mrs we're looking for a cat this
cat we've got an offer for him what
could they possibly want to
what's up Puss and Boots seriously I
told you to help Department people there
are no cats here make a tool
we're looking for the legendary pushing
boots have you perhaps
seen him too soft out with it you old
[ __ ] I'll have your gangster garters
too hard that was not just right oi baby
sniff him out you don't tell me what to
do listen to your sister baby oh she's
not my sister she's a fugitive orphan
Jesus yes sister she says fine for all I
can smell is cat pee
[Music]
treatment Papa
oh
that's in a piano
here we go
[Music]
Focus please
[Music]
amateurs I'll be outside
[Music]
oh yeah tricky little bugger I bet this
one is a ginger
is that a joke you think this scruffy
geriatric bag of bones looks like a
legend this is definitely not
there they're getting away
[Music]
nice catching up with you poos
is that a snake what are you gonna do
[Music]
this is
foreign
[Music]
foreign
trust me trust you like I did in Santa
Coloma really Santa Coloma
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I never do this but can I get your
autograph I've been following you for a
long time
right there
because it puts laps in the face of
death Bounty Hunter
so I've heard
you will find your reward does not come
easily this I tell you
everyone thinks you'll be the one to
defeat me
but no one escaped me yet
all right let's get it over with fear me
if you can
[Music]
we are gathered here today to say
goodbye to [ __ ] much
you are down to your last life
[Music]
assistant well
I'm supposed to be a Fearless hero a
legend right this is a person party
that's your party so this is where
dignity Goes To Die the year start
coming and they don't stop coming
your Puss in Boots let's talk
no hablo English
I don't speak Spanish either
funny uh what's your story my story
[Music]
what are we looking at got up nine lives
what
I think it's something happen too high
no I am on my last laugh oh no
Legend tell us
waiting to be granted
I need your help is the great posing
boots asking for help well you see yeah
but first
hey slow down I know what I'm doing
[Music]
what what what's funny nothing should be
funny
everyone is looking for a Wishing Star
I'm going to wish for everything to be
just right
[Music]
you will find your reward does not come
easily button boots Goldie Bears all
right let's get it out of here
[Music]
when you only have one life that's what
makes it special go get him tiger hey
take it easy
this is gonna be fun
[Music]
the Wishing Star is in the dark Forest
we step through as one ready one two
after you wait what
dog still alive let's go find out
I am known by many names
it's amazing to bring [ __ ] boots back
to their biggest screen it's just
nothing but a joy there's a Charisma
that Antonio does perfectly welcome to
my sister this will revolutionize truck
what
she's living life in everything he does
hey this is a party where's the beauty
all of the thrill and all of the
adventures oh my God I absolutely loved
it
the legend will never die
Puss in Boots is on the last of his Nine
Lives he's the first time that he knows
that death is a possibility
the Wishing Star who get me my lives
back but every fairy tale character or
after this Wishing Star too
[Music]
I mean you can imagine who wins
love
we're looking for the legendary pushing
boots have you perhaps seen it howdy is
this him who is this guy
you are soft boss Kitty's soft pass oh
look at her am I doing it
it's more beautiful than you can imagine
it is super fun what that's fun it just
makes you feel good when you look at
life through a positive lens adventurous
energetic exciting cute it was for me
the most spectacular form this time hey
you want to see something cool good
people accepted
[Music]
you're still here
foreign
[Music]